that's strange  the ultimate crossover has finally  happened stranger things and Parks and  Rec  I assume you've heard the comparisons to  Sir John Ralphie of Parks and Rec yes I  have  have you met Ben Schwartz at all no if  that happens that would be great that  has to happen there has to be a pic of  that yeah yeah I I hope it happens soon  that'd be so cool I mean I love that  show and he's great he's the funniest  part of the whole show and you've heard  the theories that I'm his father  yeah that should be a whole spin-off  this is me as genre alpheios dad it's  freezing jean-ralphio in Indiana now we  just need eleven to meet Leslie Knope  because you know platinum blonde hair  eating waffles in a small town in  Indiana sound familiar  yellow haired female likes waffles and  news hey maybe stranger things it's the  prequel to Parks and Rec we never knew  we needed